maintenant sur la scène fédérale la
semaine électorale a été très marqué par
les questions budgétaires
en attendant de savoir si le canada est
en récession ou pas ce qu'on sera
d'ailleurs mardi stephen harper a eu de
bien bonnes nouvelles aujourd'hui son
gouvernement a enregistré un surplus de
5 milliards de dollars entre les mois
d'avril et de juin de nouvelles
munitions donc pour le camp conservateur
daniel thibault il a été invité ici en
tant que premier ministre devant ce
congrès national de musulmans stephen
harper s'est bien gardé de jouer la
partisanerie industry
même si aujourd'hui le chef conservateur
avait de quoi alimenter ses attaques
pour les trois premiers mois de l'année
financière qui commençait en avril le
canada affiche un surplus de 5 milliards
de dollars mieux que ce qui était prévu
dans le budget a indiqué le parti dans
un communiqué dénonçant du coup la
proche de ses opposants rien pour
ébranler le chef libéral qui en
abandonnant les équilibres budgétaires
au profit de la croissance économique
prête flanc aux attaques conservatrices
je suis très à l'aise dans le fait que
je suis le seul chef en train de dire la
vérité aux québécois et aux canadiens
plus que jamais il joue la carte de la
franchise est mise sur la crédibilité de
paul martin pour appuyer son approche on
ne peut créer de l'endroit où ou
équilibrer un budget en mettant de la
croissance au nahd le construira le npd
se trompe de cible
le npd n'ont plus eu n'accorde pas trop
d'importance aux derniers états
financiers du fédéral une bonne partie
du surplus qui est annoncé dans premier
trimestre provient de la vente des
actions de gm alors un sens là c'est une
revenu non récurrent qui est tout à fait
circonstanciel et je ne pense pas que ça
reflète réellement la situation
financière du pays mais surtout thomas
mulcair doit convaincre ses militants
qu'il n'est pas en train de tirer son
parti vers le centre en promettant un
équilibre budgétaire à tout prix face à
un rival prêt à vivre avec un déficit
trop surprenant qu'il ait choisi de
livrer son message dans notre dame de
grâce westmount où le militant social
jam news défend les couleurs du npd
le npd est un parti social démocrate
mamdouh socialiste international on en
est très fier dans cette campagne où
l'économie s'impose comme thème
principal
chaque nouvelle donnée chaque nouveau
chiffre devient un élément de plus pour
alimenter les débats
la prochaine occasion ce sera mardi
quand seront publiés les plus récents
chiffres sur la croissance économique
qui indiqueront aussi le canada est en
récession
et si daniel thibault radio canada
ottawa donc le chef conservateur vente
le surplus budgétaire mais les libéraux
eux disent que le gouvernement est en
déficit dont soir andré en surface car
qui dit vrai en fait ils ont tous les
deux raison mais parle pas de la même
chose c'est à dire que stephen harper
parle des derniers mois depuis avril où
il ya effectivement surplus par contre
justin trudeau lui pend de l'ensemble
l'exercice 2015-2016 donc des mois à
venir ou là ce sera effectivement
difficile de maintenir l'excédent
budgétaire
je vous présente les chiffres officiels
du ministère des finances il ya
effectivement un excédent depuis deux
mois d'avril donc au cours des trois
premiers mois de l'exercice excédant 5
milliards de dollars ses onze fois plus
qu'à la même période l'an dernier ça a
été gonflé par plusieurs facteurs
notamment la vente des actions que le
gouvernement détenait dans general
motors mais c'est là où ça menace
l'excédent à long terme c'est que ce ne
sont pas des revenus récurrents et à
plusieurs autres facteurs qui menacent
l'excédent budgétaire c'est à dire par
exemple hausse prévue des dépenses on a
bonifié plusieurs prestations ça coûtera
plus cher au cours des prochains mois la
récession qu'on confirmera probablement
la semaine prochaine ça va grincer va
gruger les rentrées d'impôts pour les
entreprises et les particuliers
et l'hypothèse d'un excédent pour
l'ensemble de l'année statue sur un
pétrole à 55 dollar or ce moment on a 45
$ pour le prix du brut
la conclusion c'est que trois mois ça
fait pas une année et les économistes
eux doute bien qu'on aura un excédent
c'était